LAURA?
>> LAURA: THANKS SO MUCH.
AND AT 4:10 A.M., ON WEDNESDAY,
MARCH 13, CNN DID A 38-SECOND
NEWS READ ON THE CASE NOTING THE
ARREST OF CARLOS EDUARDO AREVALO
CARRANZA.
THE NEXT DAY "THE INGRAHAM
ANGLE" BROUGHT YOU THE EXCLUSIVE
NEW INFORMATION THAT LOCAL
SANCTUARY POLICIES TIED TO THIS
CRIMINAL BEING ABLE TO ROAM THE
STREETS FREELY AND ILLEGALLY,
EVEN AFTER OFFICIALS BLAMED ICE
FOR THEIR PATHETIC POLICIES.
NOW, SINCE THAT EXCLUSIVE NOT
ONE NETWORK, CABLE OR OTHERWISE,
HAS BROUGHT YOU EVEN A SINGLE
SECOND OF BAMBI LARSON'S STORY.
WHY IS THAT?
HERE'S JUST A SNIPPIT OF STORIES
THEY DEEMED MORE IMPORTANT THAN
THE BRUTAL MURDER OF AN AMERICAN
BY AN ILLEGAL IMMIGRANT.
>> TONIGHT WE HAVE AN INSIDE
LOOK OF A VERTICAL LANDMARK.
>> -- BEEN SUSPENDED FOR EIGHT
GAMES.
>> HE DIDN'T RESTRING RIGHT
HANDED GUITARS.
HE PLAYED THEM UPSIDE-DOWN.
>> LAURA: THE MEDIA IS ONE THING
BUT THE OFFICIALS TAPPED WITH
KEEPING CITIZENS SAFE IS QUITE
ANOTHER.
ON FRIDAY WE BROUGHT YOU A LIST
OF SANTA CLARA ELECTED OFFICIALS
WHO REFUSED TO APPEAR OR OFFER
ANY REAL STATEMENT ON THE RECORD
TO US AND ONLY ONE OF THOSE
OFFICIALS RESPONDED TONIGHT.
THAT'S JAMES WILLIAMS, COUNTY
COUNSEL, WHO BLAMED ICE IN HIS
NEWS CONFERENCE.
HE POINTED OUT A STATEMENT HE
GAVE THE DAY BEFORE WE REVEALED
THOSE EXCLUSIVE DOCUMENTS
SHOWING THAT COUNTY POLICY WAS
REALLY AT FAULT.
THEY PROVIDED NO UPDATE AND NO
EXPLANATION.
ONE PERSON DEMANDING ANSWERS IS
ONE OF BAMBI LARSON'S CLOSE
FRIENDS.
DIANE.
SHE'S WONDERING HOW THIS GUY WAS
EVER ALLOWED TO GO FREE AND
ALSO, HE CLAIMED ASYLUM.
CLAIMING CREDIBLE FEAR WHEN HE
CAME INTO THE UNITED STATES.
SET FREE.
SHE'S EVEN CALLING FOR HIM TO
GET THE DEATH PENALTY.
HERE NOW EXCLUSIVELY IS DIE
DIANE COLEMAN.
I'M SO SORRY FOR YOUR LOSS AND
WHAT YOU'RE GOING THROUGH.
OF COURSE, BAMBI'S SON, WHO
UNDOUBTEDLY IS TOO
GRIEF-STRICKEN TO SPEAK.
TELL ME ABOUT HER.
>> YES.
I WOULD LOVE TO TELL YOU.
FIRST OF ALL, THANK YOU FOR
HAVING ME, LAURA.
THANK YOU FOR COVERING THIS
STORY BECAUSE EVERYTHING YOU
JUST SAID IS WHAT I'VE BEEN
FEELING FOR 2 1/2 WEEKS.
I WOULD LOVE TO TELL YOU AND
YOUR AUDIENCE ABOUT MY BEAUTIFUL
FRIEND, BAMBI LARSON.
SHE WAS ONE OF THE KINDEST,
GENTLEST, CLASSIEST, MOST DECENT
PEOPLE THAT I HAD THE HONOR OF
SAYING WAS MY FRIEND.
WE MET AS YOGA STUDENTS IN 2004.
15 YEARS AGO.
AND THEN I BECAME HER TEACHER,
AND THEN WE BECAME FRIENDS.
BAMBI WAS A WOMAN WHO WAS MY
TRUE FRIEND.
SHE SHOWED UP FOR ME IN REALLY
GOOD TIMES IN MY LIFE, AND SHE
SHOWED UP FOR ME IN REALLY HARD
TIMES.
AND THE THING THAT I FEEL WAS
ESPECIALLY EXTRAORDINARY IS THAT
I NEVER HAD TO ASK THIS WOMAN TO
SHOW UP FOR ME.
SHE NEEDS ME TO SHOW UP FOR HER
NOW.
IF YOU WILL INDULGE ME, I WOULD
LIKE TO TELL YOU A REALLY
PERSONAL STORY THAT WILL GIVE
YOU AN IDEA OF JUST WHO SHE WAS.
SO I MAINLY TAUGHT BAMBI IN A
LARGE CLASS CAPACITY.
BUT FIVE YEARS AGO, MY FAMILY
AND I MOVED AND I HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE MY OWN VERY
SMALL YOGA STUDIO IN MY
BASEMENT.
I COULD NOT BEG, BORROW OR STEAL
TO GET PEOPLE TO COME TO CLASS
AND I WAS A WOMAN WHO HAD
THOUSANDS OF YOGA STUDENTS.
>> LAURA: WHAT DID SHE DO FOR
YOU?
>> EXCEPT FOR BAMBI LARSON, SO
BAMBI LARSON CAME TO MY HOME
STUDIO TWO TIMES EVERY WEEK.
NOW, THAT'S NICE ENOUGH, RIGHT?
BUT SHE ACTUALLY HAD THIS
INCREDIBLE DECENCY TO EMAIL ME
AND REGISTER ONLINE FOR EVERY
CLASS SHE TOOK, AND SHE WOULD
ASK, IN THOSE EMAILS, IF I MIGHT
HAVE SPACE FOR BAMBI LARSON.
CAN YOU IMAGINE THAT?
>> LAURA: SHE'S A TRUE FRIEND.
>> SHE WAS A TRUE FRIEND.
>> LAURA: IT'S HARD TO FIND
THEM.
I HAVE TO ASK YOU TO SPEAK FOR
HER, IF YOU COULD SAY ONE THING
TO THESE COUNTY OFFICIALS THAT
ARE TRYING TO PASS THE BLAME.
>> SURE.
>> LAURA: TO A GOVERNMENT AGENCY
THAT HAD NINE TIMES REQUEST THIS
GUY BE HELD UNTIL THEY COULD
PICK HIM UP AND GET HIM
PROCESSED OUT OF THE COUNTRY AND
THEY NEVER TURNED HIM OVER,
WHAT'S YOUR MESSAGE TO THESE
LOCAL OFFICIALS?
>> I'M HAPPY TO SPEAK FOR BAMBI.
SHAME ON YOU.
YOU HAVE BLOOD ON YOUR HANDS.
THERE IS NO REASON THIS
BEAUTIFUL, INCREDIBLE HUMAN
BEING SHOULD HAVE BEEN BUTCHERED
THE WAY THAT SHE WAS, IN HER OWN
BED, IN HER OWN HOME.
DEFENSELESS AS SHE COULD BE.
AND WHAT I WAS TRYING TO FINISH,
LAURA, WAS TO TELL YOU, WHAT
BAMBI DID FOR ME IN 2014 AND
2015, IS SHE RESTORED MY DIGNITY
AT A TIME IN MY LIFE WHERE IT
HAD BEEN STRIPPED FOR OTHER
REASONS.
I'M HERE TONIGHT TO RESTORE HERS
BECAUSE SHE WAS KILLED.
SHE WAS MURDERED IN THE MOST
UNDIGNIFIED WAY POSSIBLE.
AND THAT'S NOT OKAY WITH ME.
AND I DON'T WANT TO HEAR THAT
SHE'S A ONE OFF.
I DON'T WANT TO HEAR THE BUCK
BEING PASSED FROM ONE DEPARTMENT
TO THE NEXT.
I WANT PEOPLE TO KNOW THIS WAS A
REAL PERSON WHO DESERVED TO BE
SAFE IN HER OWN BED.
SHE WAS LAW-ABIDING.
SHE WAS A TAX PAYING CITIZEN.
SHE WAS A HOMEOWNER.
SHE WAS A MOTHER.
SHE WOULD HAVE LOVED TO HAVE
BECOME A GRANDMOTHER.
SHE WAS INCREDIBLE.
SHE WAS AS GOOD AS SHE LOOKS IN
THE PHOTOGRAPH THAT I HAVE
PROVIDED FOR YOU.
>> LAURA: SHE HAS THAT WARMTH.
SHE EXCEEDS.
YOU CAN SEE IT IN THE PHOTOS.
SHE JUST EXCEEDS, HAPPY, NICE
PERSON, WHICH YOU CAN SEE.
>> HAPPY.
NICE.
OPEN.
>> LAURA: I HAVE TO ASK YOU
ABOUT THE SANCTUARY POLICIES
THAT ALLOW THESE KIND OF THINGS
TO CONTINUE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
SHOULD THIS BE A LESSON?
>> ARE YOU KIDDING?
OF COURSE.
AND THE BEST PART ABOUT BEING ON
YOUR SHOW IS I WANT PRESIDENT
TRUMP'S EAR AND HE IS MY
PRESIDENT.
AND I'M PROUD TO CALL HIM THAT.
AND THERE ARE GOOD HEARTED
CALIFORNIANS WHO THINK THIS IS
CRAZY, IMMIGRANT FRIENDS OF MINE
AMONG THEM WHO THINK THIS IS
CRAZY BECAUSE IT IS.
PEOPLE TELL ME THAT I'M
COURAGEOUS TO SPEAK, THIS IS NOT
COURAGE.
THIS IS A RIGHT AND WRONG AND
THERE IS -- IT'S ABSOLUTELY
BLACK AND WHITE.
IT'S BEYOND COMMON SENSE.
SHE WAS RAISED BY GOOD PARENTS.
>> LAURA: WE'RE OUT OF TIME BUT
WE'LL FOLLOW THIS STORY.
I'M SURE WE'LL HAVE YOU BACK.
>> OKAY.
>> LAURA: --
>> MY MESSAGE IS, PLEASE,
PRESIDENT TRUMP, I BEG OF YOU,